[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم قطر والسعوديه ت ندد
بتصريحات الوزيرين الاسرائيليين سموتريتش
وبن كفير حول تهجير الفلسطينيين من غزه
واعاده احتلال القطاع وبناء المستوطنات
فيه الخارجيه القطريه قالت ان هذه تصريحات
لا تغير من حقيقه ان الارض ستظل فلسطينيه
والخارجيه السعوديه تصفها بانها متطرفه
تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط
التعليق الاول قتيلان وجرحى في قصف على
مقر للحشد الشعبي شرقي بغداد حركه النجباء
العراقيه تؤكد مقتل القائد البارز في
الحشد طالب السعيدي ومصدر في الحشد الشعبي
يرجح ان تكون طائره امريكيه نفذت القصف
ورئيس الوزراء العراقي يصف العمليه بانها
تصعيد خطير يتجاوز نص تفويض التحالف
الدولي في
العراق فرقه مكافحه الارهاب في تونس تعتقل
الزميل سمير ساسي الصحفي بمكتب قناه
الجزيره وتقده الى جهه مجهوله وقد دهمت
الفرقه منزل الزميل وفتشته وصادرت هواتفه
وحاسوب الشخصي قبل اعتقاله محامون يفيدون
بانهم لم يتمكنوا من معرفه اسباب القرار
وخلفياته بعد استقالتها من منصبها رئيسه
جامعه هارفرد السابقه كلودين جي تعترف
بارتكابها اخطاء لكنها تعتبر انها كانت
عرضه لحمله من الاكاذيب والاهانات يذكر ان
كلودين تعرضت لهجوم شرس على خلفيه شهادتها
في الكونجرس حول معاداه الساميه في
الجامعه واتهامات لها بالسرقه الادبيه الى
اللقاء
ه